[MUSIC PLAYING]
VAN RIPER: Hi.
I'm Van Riper, from the Google
Developer Relations Team and
the program manager for our
Google Developer Groups, which
are our local meetups run
by the community.
We have over 300 of them in
95 countries to date.
And I'm kicking off
this what we call
Google Developer Groups--
the GDGs--
All Hands monthly intro to
various product areas, with a
talk from Pete LePage from the
Google Chrome Developer
Relations Team.
I want to thank Peter Lubbers
from the Chrome team as well,
as well as Louis Gray, who's
is also in the studio here
with me in Mountain View for
Google Developers Live--
for the infrastructure to
do these kind of talks.
And now I'm going to turn
it over to Pete in
our New York office.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Thanks very much, Van.
It's awesome to be here.
And thanks for getting everybody
together to talk
about Chrome apps.
I think it's a really exciting
evolution of some of the stuff
that we have.
And I think it's something
that a lot of the Google
Developers are going to get
really excited about, because
it means that you can build apps
that look and feel native
on your desktop, just using
HTML and web technologies.
So why don't we jump in?
I've got a couple of slides
that I want to walk folks
through and show a few things as
we go so that you can get a
little bit of an idea of what's
going on with Chrome
apps, how you can use them,
and why they're so cool.
So let's start by having a look
at a couple of the key
points about Chrome apps.
So there's four things we're
going to cover today.
First we're going to talk about
how Chrome apps break
out of the browser.
They don't feel like
web apps anymore.
They now feel like they are
installed, native apps.
The second thing we're going to
talk about is the enhanced
user interface.
So how you can really take all
of the stuff that you're used
to using today and really
be able to make a really
beautiful user interface that
looks and feels like a native
app, without looking like
the stuff that you
see on the web today.
We'll talk about how these apps
work offline, by default.
This is one of the coolest
things, I think, about this
new Chrome packaged
app platform.
It means that your apps work
offline, by default.
Everything that you're used
to being able to have with
offline apps, just
right there.
And then finally, we'll talk
about some of the new APIs,
things that you can do with
these Chrome apps that you
just simply can't do with
the drive-by web.
Drive-by web is a great place,
but do you really want to open
up things like USB or networking
APIs in case
somebody gets access to them
in some not so nice, not so
friendly kind of way.
So I think the best thing to do
is actually just start off
and how to look at a
couple of demos.
So I've got here on
my computer a
couple of things running.
And of course, I
always do this.
You move your mouse to the wrong
place, and you kick your
screen saver in.
So let's not do that again.
So I'm going to bring
up Chrome.
In fact, the slide deck that
we're looking at is a Chrome
app as well.
But the ones I want to take a
look at are here already.
So today, with Chrome apps,
they're being launched from
the New Tab page.
In the future, they'll get
launched either from the task
bar or from a launcher.
But right now, we're
still in a little
bit of an early phase.
And so I'll bring one up.
So this is weather app.
It's telling you that, here in
New York, it's 45 degrees and
a high of 50 today.
I want to point out a couple
of things though.
Notice that there's no
address bar here.
There's no look and feel that
this looks like a web
application.
I can move it around.
I can, interestingly,
close it using a
different close mechanism.
It doesn't have the typical--
on this Mac that I'm using--
the X, the minus,
and the plus sign.
But you can have those
experiences if you want.
I'll bring up a calculator.
And again, these are just a
couple simple examples that
you can have a look at.
But notice the calculator
does have those pieces.
Again, no address bar or
anything like that.
If I wanted to be so brave, I
could go turn my network off.
So my Wi-Fi is off.
If I start the calculator again,
sure enough, it works.
It behaves exactly like
I expect it to.
There's no real need for
network connection.
I can say on this, one
plus one equals two.
Woo-hoo.
So we know that our
math works.
OK.
One of my favorite and, I think,
more interesting apps
right now is something that one
of the guys on the Chrome
Dev Rel Team worked on.
And it was a Markdown app.
We'll talk about why this is
kind of cool in a sec.
But I wanted to show you
a couple other things.
I can go create a new file.
I can open a file.
I can save it or print it.
So I'm just going to go here,
and I'm going to open this
file, grab this Markdown file.
So one of the things to notice
is I can open files anywhere
on my desktop.
And sure enough, here's
the file.
And we've got two pieces here.
We've got the left hand panel
here, which has the Markdown,
and the right hand panel that
shows the actual Markdown
rendered in the HTML.
The really neat thing is that
you can edit this on the fly,
live, in real time.
So I can do things like,
oh yeah, I just
don't really want that.
[? Is it ?] one or two?
So you've got the ability to
be able to go and edit
Markdown in real time.
One of the neat things about
this is it's actually using
Node in the back end to do the
compilation and convert the
Markdown into HTML and render
that HTML in the application.
So let's close this guy.
And I'm going to bring my
Chrome app back up,
along with my slides.
And let's go and move on a
little bit and take a look at
a couple other points in here.
So we saw the demos,
a couple of these.
Let's talk first about that what
it really means to break
out of the browser.
So when I talk about breaking
out of the browser, one of the
big things that I'm really
talking about is that they're
launched from outside
the browser.
Now today, unfortunately we
don't have that in today's
Chrome build.
But the plan is that you'll be
able to go to the Start menu,
you'll be able to go to the
Dock, or wherever you launch
your applications, and you'll be
able to go and launch those
apps without having to go
and do anything crazy.
It's not like you have
to open the browser.
And that's a really important
thing, because users think
about the web as something
that only works
when they're connected.
These apps work when they're
disconnected, when they're not
necessarily on the network.
So getting them out of the
browser is a really important
thing so that there isn't a
level of confusion there for
some users.
The other thing is that these
apps have the same first-class
feel as other OS windows.
So that means you can alt+tab
between them.
You can go in and you can see
the apps that are running in
your task list.
They have that same look and
feel that you expect from a
native application.
In terms of the enhanced user
interface, there's a couple of
neat things.
We've seen some of
these already.
You've got full control
over multiple windows.
In a web app, you can pop open
a new window, but typically
it'll get blocked by
a pop-up blocker.
Or if you go to do something
where you just don't expect
certain behaviors,
you may have that
stopped in its tracks.
And because you've got that
address bar, you really have
that concept of that
single window.
You also have full customization
of the frame,
without the browser Chrome.
You noticed when I brought
up a couple of those apps
earlier, we didn't have
the address bar.
We didn't have the
browser frame.
We didn't have the things
that you typically
expect out of the web.
Links open in a new tab, so that
if I go and click on this
link, sure enough, it
opens in my browser.
Now it's not going to open
anything, because I've
disconnected myself
from the network.
So let's go ahead and turn
the network back on.
And we'll go back to
the slides here.
So the links open in the
app, not the browser.
The third point is that these
apps work offline by default.
They work offline by default,
because they use the same
packaged app experience that
we have in the current
packaged app system, where
all of the resources--
the HTML, the JavaScript, the
CSS, all of the images--
sit locally on the
user's computer.
So when they click Install,
it really is installing
everything that they need to
be able to run this app.
Just like when they click on
Install for any other native
application--
whether they install it through
a CD, whether they
install it through an app
store or whatever--
that app runs locally because
all the resources are sitting
on the user's machine.
We also enforced separation
of some of the
client UI and data.
We do that because the client UI
is sitting on the computer,
and we need to go get that data
from the network somehow.
So either through making XML
HTTP AJAX request, or maybe
you've got some other
way of getting data
into the user's machine.
For example, in the Markdown
app, where I just opened the
file locally, hit File, Open.
And sure enough, I was able to
load the data from there.
The APIs are also something
really interesting.
We're providing a bunch of new
APIs that are available, that
will provide new
functionality.
So things like being able to
access USB, and networking,
and Bluetooth.
But we're also providing a set
of APIs that will do things
like provide analytics or
user authentication.
Right now, you try and go
authenticate a user and
they're disconnected from the
net, it's going to be a little
bit hard to do that.
So the important thing here, is
that we want to make sure
that these APIs degrade
gracefully, so that you don't
have to go and handle
the-- like, ah
crap, how do I do this?
How do I go and make sure that
my behavior is right?
It's really important to make
sure that we do this right.
And then finally, again, I'll
come back to this one.
But again, the apps
are launched
from outside the browser.
Removing that confusion from
folks going, oh, crap.
I'm on the web right now.
So I'm using my browser.
That means this isn't going to
work, or it is going to work.
The experience just works
because users are launching
the app from outside
of their browser.
Now there's a whole
bunch of new APIs.
And this is an area that is
tremendously exciting.
There are so many new things
that I think developers are
going to be able to
do with this.
First, there's a set of system
APIs that are going to allow
you access to the system that
you've never had access to
before through the web.
You always had to go and either
write a native app, or
maybe you had to go and write
some kind of plug-in, or some
other experience that
just wasn't a lot of
fun for us to do.
I like writing JavaScript.
I don't like writing C++.
I don't like writing Java.
I want to write my apps
using JavaScript.
So by giving access to system
APIs, we can do that through
JavaScript.
Some of the new system APIs that
we're giving access to
include things like USB.
So if you plug a USB device into
your computer, you can
access those devices.
You can send commands to them.
You can get interesting data
back and forth from them.
One of the things that the
team's been working on is
getting a Kinect to work so that
you can use the Kinect as
some kind of input to your
applications, that you can
turn that into gaming
input for web games.
Something pretty slick--
really neat to be able to do.
We've got networking APIs.
In fact, one of the
networking APIs--
there's a couple of them.
There's TCP, send and receive,
and there's also
UDP send and receive.
That means you can open up a
port and work as a server.
You could write a web server
within a browser, which is a
little bit meta, but
kind of cool.
You actually get the browser
being able to serve stuff.
You can also send just TCP
requests and send TCP data
over the network.
So for things like, the new
Phillips Hue, those new lights
that are controllable via
networking, you can actually
go and control those through
a web application.
I've seen things like
IR controllers
that work over TCP.
So you send a TCP connection
to the IR controller.
And then the IR controller
sends out an IR blast.
Maybe it turns your TV on.
Maybe it turns your air
conditioner on.
Whatever the case is, you
can go through and
be able to get that.
There's also a set of
Shared Data APIs.
Shared Data APIs allows us to
very easily go in and say,
hey, I want to be able to
store data on the user's
computer, or be able to load
data from alternate sources.
If you're a Chrome user, you're
used to being signed
into your browser, probably, and
love the fact that Chrome
remembers who you are and your
usernames, passwords, your
bookmarks, all that kind of
stuff across all the different
devices that you're on.
Well, with these Shared Data
APIs, as an application, we
can also store data, our
application data, in the
Google Cloud, so that when I
sign in on my computer, it
works just fine.
But if I then go switch to
another computer and sign into
Chrome, start this app up, all
of that data is all synced
down just in the same
way that it was if I
had used my own computer.
Finally, there's a set of
Service APIs that we're
working on.
So these will include things
like being able
to do Google Analytics.
So I can see, how many people
are using my app?
And I can track those
kinds of things.
Google Authentication, so that I
can sign in and validate the
user as who they say they are.
Hopefully they think they are
who they really are, because
that would be a little
confusing.
But being able to
validate users.
And there's a bunch of other
service level APIs that we're
working on and will be coming
over the next little while.
The programming model is the
same, or very similar to
Chrome apps.
If you've written a Chrome
packaged app in the past,
under the current Chrome Web
Store, you're already probably
80% of the way there.
It's based on that Chrome
packaged app where all the
resources sit locally.
The one thing that changes is
instead of having the index
files, that first file that
gets loaded when the
application starts, there's a
background page that works
sort of as the hub.
If you've written any kind of
native code-- maybe a native
mobile app, maybe a Windows
or a Mac app--
you're used to having that main
function body that kicks
off the app, that opens that
first form, or opens that
first window.
It's very similar.
And we'll take a look
at the code.
We're actually going to go and
write a Hello World app and
take a look at some other
examples in a minute.
The app lifetime is controlled
by the run time.
And it's all event driven, so
that you could say, when the
app starts, do this.
When the window closes,
do this.
You've got that control and
ability to be able to do
whatever you need to do.
It is single-page, and there
isn't really that concept of
navigation.
There's no address bar
there anymore.
So you can't go back and forth
between different pages.
You can't do those
kinds of things.
Now you can load different
pages.
You can open different
windows.
But the core concept is around
that single-page application.
There are few web features
that are deprecated for a
couple of reasons.
So for things like
window.navigation, window.URL
because they just don't make
sense when you don't have the
address bar.
There's a couple others.
And there's some good
documentation on what's gone
away and why it's changed, as
well as good alternatives for
how you can go use some
of those things.
So let's talk for a moment
about the security model.
I already noticed a couple
questions pop up from people
saying, hey, so what about the
security model on this?
Or somebody asked, well,
what about viruses?
Well, the security
model is really
around process isolation.
So that means that applications,
your app, is
running in its own
isolated window.
So sandbox, just like
other Chrome apps,
you don't have to--
and other web pages.
They're not going to be
able to access other
applications' data.
They're not going to be able to
get into things that they
shouldn't be able to get into.
But they also have a set
of permissions model.
That means that applications
need to ask permission before
they can do certain things.
For example, if you don't have
the USB permission, you can't
use the USB APIs.
If you don't have the networking
permissions, you
can't use the networking APIs.
So we really tried to make sure
that when a user installs
an application, they know what
APIs are available and what
APIs that the application
is being called.
So that, they can make an
informed decision about how to
go and whether they want to
trust that application or not.
Because these apps are running
HTML and JavaScript, there
really isn't an easy
way for viruses in
the traditional sense.
So it's much more about
protecting user data.
Which actually leads perfectly
into the next comment, which
is something called Content
Security Policy.
If you're not familiar with
Content Security Policy,
there's a great article up on
HTML5Rocks that I really
recommend you check out.
HTML5Rocks' article on
"Introduction to Content
Security Policy" lays out all
of the great details.
Short description of it--
Content Security Policy helps
protect applications from
cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities.
So typically, when a web app
or a website is hit with a
cross-site scripting
vulnerability, it's because
somebody's able to inject a
bunch of JavaScript into
somebody else's application.
So if a bad guy manages to
inject some JavaScript into
MyBank.com, and when I go sign
in on MyBank, that JavaScript
sends my username and password
back to his website.
So all of a sudden, evilguy.com
is able to get
stuff that I don't necessarily
want to share.
Now the way that Content
Security Policy helps to
protect web applications from
cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities is by limiting
where script can run and how
it can run.
So typically, when on any page,
if you don't have any
Content Security Policy rules in
place, you could put script
in line in your HTML.
You could do evals.
You could do all kinds of things
that are interesting to
do and typically some
of the things that
we're used to doing.
Content Security Policy, the
rules that are implemented
within Chrome apps, limit you
from putting any inline
JavaScript within your HTML.
So that means that you can't do
the script, close bracket,
blah blah blah blah blah, and
put some script in there.
You have to link to a
script source file.
You actually have to put your
script into a separate file.
We'll take a look at this when
we do some of the demos.
The other thing that this limits
you from being able to
do is anything like eval, or
return new function, or any
equivalents to that
kind of thing.
So if you're used to using evals
or anything like that,
you're going to need to
change that process
just a little bit.
In some cases, some MVC
frameworks and some templating
libraries do use eval.
We're working with some of those
templating libraries to
try and get them to switch
and not use those.
But you may run into that issue
if you're using any of
these things.
There's also storage
isolation.
So any data that you store for
the user's profile doesn't get
shared between apps.
There's no way to get
any additional data.
And there's an explicit
shared data API.
So we're really limiting
some of the stuff.
And finally, you don't have
access to some of the
extension APIs.
One, it doesn't really make
sense to be able to go grab,
like, the tabs in Chrome.
Because you're an application
that has nothing to do with
the browser, even though
you're written on web
technology.
I want to call out one other
cool and different thing.
There's a Web View control, that
if you want to go and put
live web content into your
app, you can use
this Web View control.
So you notice there,
I've got Web View.
And all I do is open Web View,
provide a source, link to that
particular place, and
it renders that.
So that's particularly useful
if in your application you
want to be running--
or you want to put ads in your
application, and your ads are
going to get served live, or
something to that effect.
So the Web View is just an easy
way that you can put live
HTML into your application.
All right.
So I think I've talked
too much.
Let's actually go and take a
look at building our own
Chrome app.
So I'm going to get
out of here.
So I'll close this down.
So I've got the basics here in
Sublime for what I want to
show and what I need.
So first off, there's basically
three steps that we
need to walk through in order to
be able to write our first
Chrome app.
So the first thing we need to do
is edit our manifest file.
So if you've written a Chrome
app before and you're used to
the manifest file, you've seen
it before, maybe you've
written a Chrome extension the
manifest file is very similar.
It's basically a JSON file
that defines how the
application should get its
resources, where is should get
its files, and all that
kind of stuff.
So let's go ahead,
and we'll start.
So I'm going to say name.
And hello there.
All right.
So we've defined our name.
Next thing we need
is a description.
Always fun to type live.
This is my description.
I love it when it auto completes
stuff for me.
We need a version number.
So I'm going to say let's
call this 0.5.
One little hint for folks, as
you start to put your apps in,
don't go with version 0.1.
Because if you upload an app
that's 0.1, users are going to
go look at it and be like, why
would I want to install 0.1?
That's like before beta.
So put a reasonable
version number.
So our case, seeing that this
is only going to be a Hello
World app, I think we can safely
say this is a 0.9.
So the next thing we need to do
is define how our app is.
And this is another
adjacent object.
And so we're going to
say, background.
And the background is defining
what background script that we
need to run.
So I'm just going
to say, scripts.
And I'm going to give it an
array, and with just one
single item, with main.js.
So that's going to say, this
background script--
this main.js--
is the file that you want
to load immediately.
It's like when you're writing
native apps, it's that same
thing that's got the application
start code in it.
Next thing we want to do is add
some icons, because it's
always nice to have some
icons for our app.
We want some nice, high
quality stuff.
So I'm going to go and add
a 16 by 16 pixel icon.
And I'll say, image,
icon, 16.png.
And I also want to have a 128
pixel by 128 pixel icon.
So that way I've got a nice,
good size image for wherever I
need it to show up.
So img, icon, 128.
So there's our icons.
I guess I don't need
that there.
And that's the manifest file.
That's everything that I need.
The key thing that I want to
highlight here is this one
piece here, which has got
the background script.
So let's go ahead and
save that file.
The next thing we need to do
for step two is actually go
write our main JavaScript
file.
So again, this is the file
that kicks off our
application.
This is the file that says,
hey, we're good to go.
And when the app starts,
this is the one
that we want to use.
So let's start here.
This app uses the Chrome
namespace.
So I'm going to say, Chrome.app,
runtime.
And we want to add an
onLaunched listener.
So launched, add listener,
and function--
I'm just going to move this down
so that we can see this.
There we go.
Function--
and pop that guy there.
So now, inside our event
listener, we're going to say
Chrome.app.window.create.
And this is going to go and
create a new window with
window.html.
And we'll define
that in a sec.
And then we want to provide
some properties to that
particular window.
So I want it to open
at width of 400--
oops, close that.
We don't want that.
There we go.
And a height of 500.
So that's really all we need.
So basically, what's going to
happen now, Chrome is going to
listen for when this application
is launched.
When it's launched, it's going
to create a new window using
the Window HTML file.
And it's going to create
that window as a 400
by 500 pixel window.
So we can go in, and we can
do that final piece.
I'm using Sublime, so I'm going
to cheat a little bit.
And I'm going to go in
and just put in the
basis for my stuff.
So this is my Hello There app.
And I've already written a
little bit of CSS, because I
figured you guys didn't want
to see me write CSS.
It gets a little bit boring.
So we'll put our CSS file
in there as main.CSS.
And I'm going to put
this in as an H1.
Hello there, everyone.
Let's just do "hello there."
Hello world.
Got to go for the
standard stuff.
So now I'm going to save that.
I'm going to save
my main.js file.
And I've also saved
my manifest file.
So those are the three
things that you need.
Notice that in here, I've got my
two icons, so the icon 128
and icon 16.
I know they're a little small,
but you can trust me that
they're there.
And let's go and grab
Chrome Canary.
And just to prove that this is
all working offline, I'll turn
off my Wi-Fi again.
And we need to go into
the Extensions tab.
So if you're not familiar
on how to get to
the Extensions tab--
I'll just close this so
that we can see--
you click on the three little
guys here, go to Tools, and
click on Extensions.
And that will open up
the Extensions tab.
One thing that you want to make
sure that you do is check
this little check box here, the
Developer Mode check box,
because that's going to make
sure that Chrome is in
Developer Mode.
If that's not checked, notice
that the Load Unpacked
Extensions goes away.
So we want to make sure
that that's checked.
So now I'm going to say Load
Unpacked Extensions.
And I'm going to go and grab
the one that I just wrote.
So here it is.
Pointing to the directory,
I'll click Select.
Ha ha.
All right.
Always fun.
If there's any kind of problem
with your application as
you're working on these things,
you'll get an error
right off the bat telling
you, hey, there's
something going on here.
You're not quite right.
So sure enough, I created a
backup directory just in case
I had any typos.
So I need to go get
rid of that.
So let's just go, and we'll
rename this backup directory,
and we'll call it,
XXXXXXX backup.
There we go.
So bring Chrome back up.
And again, we'll load the
unpacked extension.
I'll click Select.
And sure enough, there it is
there, "Hello World." I'll
open a new tab and there's
my Hello There app.
So this is the same thing
that we saw, that we
were working on.
When I clicked on it, here's
"Hello World." So
my app is now up.
It's running, success.
We have "Hello World."
We're set.
We're good to go.
Now I want to point out a couple
of little things that,
as you're working on these
apps, that you can dive a
little bit deeper into how
to debug these things.
So first thing to note, is that
if you want to go in and
bring up the developer tools,
well, you can't.
Like Control-Shift-J
or Command--
Option J, it's not there.
And because there's no browser
frame, I can't go and click on
the little icons.
What I can do, because we're in
Developer Mode right now,
and this is an application that
I installed myself, I can
right-click on this, and I can
go in, and I can see Reload
Page, Reload App, Inspect
Element, or
Inspect Background Page.
So I'm going to go and just
say Inspect Element.
And sure enough, here's
my standard set
of developer tools.
I can go in, and I can do all
this stuff that I'm used to
being able to do within Chrome's
Developer Tools.
So I can maybe go turn
off centering.
I can go in and I can say, oh,
hey, I want to go to the
console and find out
what's going on on
some of these things.
So you have the full set of
developer tools that you're
used to being able to use
completely within Chrome apps.
You can go into the resources,
being able to see all the
files that are getting loaded.
You can see anything else that's
going on and know, all
right, great, sweet.
We're good to go.
I'm happy.
All right.
So let me close this out.
And I want to take a look at the
code for the calculator.
So I'm going to go and grab the
Now all of this code
is available.
If you want to go and start
playing with some of these
yourself, the link is down on
the bottom of the page.
We've got a really phenomenal
set of resources that you can
go and sample apps that you
can go download on GitHub.
That's where that link
will take you.
So I'll go grab the calculator,
open this guy up.
So sure enough, you can see in
the calculator, we've just got
a set of divs with
some buttons.
Our controller, which is
where our view is in
this particular case.
We're using an MVC framework.
It's right here.
I can go in and see
my main.js.
Now interestingly, with
this main.js--
I'll move this down so we can
see a couple of these things.
So remember how I
had window.HTML.
This you can load whatever
file you happen to want.
I just put in height and width
in my previous example.
But in this case,
they set both a
height minimum and maximum.
So that actually means that I
can't resize that window.
So you've got the same set of
experiences as you'd expect to
be able to have in native
applications.
You can go through and you can
actually minimize and maximize
those things and really
be able to do a
lot of great things.
We've got all of our framework
stuff here, so that you can go
through and see, OK, so this
is how we handle all of our
application.
And then the view for
this application.
So again, that same thing
where everything is all
available to you,
quickly, easily.
And you can go through and
build some of these out
yourself without going into
anything too crazy.
So with that, what I want to
do is open it up to some of
your questions that you guys
have as we're going through.
So I'm going to bring Van
up here in a second.
Van, you're on screen now,
and folks can hear you.
I'm going to pop over to some
of the questions that I've
already popped into
Google Moderator.
I'm also going to put
the link up here.
So if you've got questions
and you want to ask your
questions, you can post your
questions to that URL there
through Google Moderator.
So let's take the
first question.
And the first question
from Rob in Montana--
or MT--
is, "Will Chrome apps be
available on mobile Chrome?"
And I'm really excited say,
yeah, they will be.
We're still working through some
of the implementation.
Yeah.
This is really cool because it
means that you can write your
app with the same set of code in
one place, and you can get
it to work across multiple
devices.
So not only will it work on a
Mac, and on a PC, and on a
Chromebook, but it will also
work on and an iOS device and
on an Android device.
We still have a few details to
work through and to make sure
that we get this right.
Because we want to make sure
we get it absolutely right.
But that's something that
we're working on.
And expect to see more about
that in the next, hopefully,
couple weeks.
So keep an eye out for that.
So the next question. "Does the
Chrome Apps Team have any
plans to work with any of the
Mobile Team to allow Chrome
apps?" I think we just
kind of hit that one.
The one thing I will call out
on the way that we're doing
this is that basically
we're doing it
through Cordova or PhoneGap.
So your app will get wrapped
in PhoneGap.
We're putting a lot of effort
and a lot of energy into the
Cordova project, the PhoneGap
project, to make sure that the
project is really great, that it
rocks, that the experience
is good for us as developers,
but as well as for consumers.
Now 90% of our code is probably
going to work across
devices without any
modification.
But you will have to remember
the screen on a phone is a
little bit different than that
on a tablet and is different
than that on a laptop
or desktop.
As well, some of the
interactions are different.
So you will have to have
different code for each app.
But the core components of your
app will remain the same.
Joshua in Fresno, wants to know,
when's the store going
to start accepting
Chrome apps?
Well, Joshua, I don't
have an exact date.
But keep an eye on the
Chromium blog,
blog.chromium.org, because I
expect to see an announcement
about that sometime
pretty soon .
We've got all the little
stuff together.
We're just doing those last
little things to make sure
that we get everything right.
And then we want to hear
your feedback.
When we do put them up in the
store to begin with, it'll
primarily be a developer
preview.
So end users aren't going to be
able to go find those apps
really easily.
They're going to have to go to
a particular URL that you'll
provide them.
Because we want to make sure
that we don't launch them
before they're ready.
We want you to make sure that
the upload experience is
right, that for us the
download and install
experience is beautiful.
So I guess that's the answer
to that question.
Greg wants to know, "Does the
newly created window with
frame none property require a
user to re-implement all of
the standard Chrome window
features, including
drag-to-move and reposition?"
So no, Greg.
You're lucky there.
You don't have to re-implement
that.
That was something I didn't
show in my demo today.
But you saw it in the weather
app, where it didn't have the
standard buttons.
If you put frame none, you've
got your own set.
So when the user drags the app
around all of that stuff, you
don't have to go in and
re-implement that or
anything like that.
Van, do we have any questions
from our live folks before I
move on to the next question?
VAN RIPER: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] are you there?
His question is, I
think, one of the
next ones from Friedger.
He's responding right now.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
I'll do the next one and then
we'll come to his question.
VAN RIPER: Here he is.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
VAN RIPER: Make sure you
are un-muted, Friedger.
Are you un-muted Friedger?
PETE LEPAGE: The fun
of live stuff.
While Friedger works
on un-muting,
I'll answer this question.
What happened to
Chrome.webrequest?
It seems to be deprecated
in V2.
Will it be coming back?
All right.
There we go.
Friedger, you have a question.
FRIEDGER: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Friedger, we'll come to your
question in a sec.
I think I see it there on the
next question so-- what
happened to Chrome
Web Requests?
It seems to be deprecated.
I mentioned earlier that some
of the Chrome extension APIs
have been deprecated.
So particularly, the
Chrome.webrequest is one of
those ones that has
been deprecated.
You can't get access
to that anymore.
And there's a couple
of things.
But keep in mind, you have an
entire HTTP area, an entire
network stack.
So you could go make your own
web requests if you wanted to.
As well, you can do an
XML HTTP request.
For the most part, you really
shouldn't need the web request
extension API, because that's
for modifying requests that go
out on other websites, maybe to
do some kind of blocking,
or maybe adding headers and
that kind of thing.
So you really shouldn't
need it.
If you do need it, and if you
have a particular use case for
it, please file a bug
at crbug.com.
You can go to new.crbug.com and
file a bug and say, hey,
this is why I need it.
Give us those reasons so that
it makes it a little bit
easier for us.
So Friedger, I know you're
joining us a
little bit live here.
Well I guess there's--
there is no little bit live.
You are either live or not.
In any event.
So what's the security model?
I heard someone saying that I
could access my NFC Reader
from Chrome apps.
So we touched on this a
little bit earlier.
The security model is really
around permissions.
Does the application ask for
permission for this?
And then does it use it?
So when you install an app,
you're told what APIs or what
permissions the application,
just like you get when you
install an app through the
Android Play Store.
What are the services
that this wants?
Do you want to allow
this or not?
And you can say yes.
You can say no, and make your
decision based on that.
NFC isn't something we
have access to today,
unfortunately, because that's
not in most computers.
If you had an NFC USB reader,
you could probably do it that
way though, because there's
USB access.
You can get to it that way.
So Van, from Silicon Valley.
Hey, I know this guy.
Do you want to ask your
question, Van?
VAN RIPER: Sure.
So I wanted to ask on behalf
of all of our GDG
organizers out there.
I mean, obviously, they
could show this.
This will be recorded and
will be available later.
But there are other resources
you could provide that they
could use to do local meetups?
And I guess this would just be
a shout out to everyone to go
look at
GoogleDevelopers.com/Groups.
Find your local meetup, because
hopefully some of
these guys will be doing meetups
around Chrome apps.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
That would be really awesome.
I just put up a link to our
developer documentation.
I just put the short link up
there, because it doesn't
really fit on screen.
Hang on.
Where is it?
There it is.
But you can also get it at
developer.chrome.com.
And there's a link down towards
the bottom that says,
Chrome apps.
Click on that link.
And all of the developer
documentation is there.
And then the second piece that
I think I called this one out
earlier was some
of the samples.
We have about 20 Chrome app
samples that are already
written, ready to go, that you
can go and grab, that you can
go through and try yourself.
You can install them
using Chrome.
As well, the slide deck that
I used today, there's a
modified, slightly older version
up there that you can
go and-- so if you want to run
through a similar slide deck,
that slide deck, as a Chrome
app, is already up there.
So that you've got
the slide deck.
You've got some demos
good to go.
You can use this recording as
some good talking points.
And I expect to see
some more stuff.
One of the really cool ones--
and in fact, I'm going to stop
talking for a sec.
Well, I'll keep talking, but I'm
going to show you guys, I
think, a cool video.
When we first started working on
Chrome apps at Google-- or
announced them at I/O, one of
the things we wanted to do is
get it working with Bluetooth.
And one of our guys spent a
little bit of time, figured
out how to get the LEGO
Mindstorm kit working with
Bluetooth, controlled
from a Chrome app.
So we were doing serial
over Bluetooth,
using the GamePad API.
Well, you guys can see
what's up there.
So there's a ton of really
neat things that
you can do with this.
So if you're going to have
a meetup or a Hangout, or
something like that, I would
strongly recommend, go find
something that you can go play
with, kind of like this.
One of the other ones that's
up there, it's a little bit
more expensive to go
get, but it is
absolutely worth every penny--
though you will probably need
two of them because you'll
wreck one--
is the Parrot AR drone.
We figured out how to control
the Parrot AR drone from a
Chrome app.
So basically, it uses UDP,
network packets that it sends
back and forth.
So how much fun would it be to
start your meetup by flying a
helicopter over the audience
and controlling it through
your computer?
Some really cool things that
you can do with that.
VAN RIPER: Anyone that does
that, I'll send them a mini
banner they can put on their
helicopter, GDG banner that
they can put on that
helicopter.
PETE LEPAGE: Sweet.
Very nice.
Controlling that helicopter
is just super cool.
It's one of those really,
really fun things.
So the next question from
Mooseman on the internet.
"Can I build an app with a
script that updates files in
the package from either my
server or the Chrome Web
Store?" And Mooseman, that's
a wonderful question.
And a lot of people are
sort of going, huh.
So if all the resources
are sitting here,
how do I go get stuff?
Or how do I go--
maybe I've got some kind of news
app where I need to go
pull data, and I want to
pull images and all
that kind of stuff.
That's a wonderful question.
Yes, you can.
And there's a couple of ways
that you can do it.
One of the ways that you could
do it is obviously making XML
HTTP requests--
AJAX request-- to go pull
the stuff down.
And then you can cache it
locally on the user's machine.
There's a couple of places
you can cache it.
You have access to the HTML5
file system APIs.
So you can store the files
there, so that you can just
quickly load them right off the
file system to be able to
render them there.
You could also store in the
Chrome Storage APIs.
I mentioned earlier.
There's two of them.
There's a Sync Storage API,
and a Local Storage API.
You can't store big stuff in
the Sync one, but you can
store some reasonable size
stuff in the local one.
Obviously, the local one is
not going to get cached
between computers.
There's also IndexedDB
and Web SQL.
I'd recommend going with
IndexedDB over Web SQL just
because IndexedDB is
that thing that
works across most places.
And it's the spec that's
still supported.
Web SQL has been a deprecated
spec, even though it is
implemented in a bunch
of other places.
So the next question from
Hussain and the Colorado GDG
in Colorado.
Will the new APIs work on
Chrome OS, and with
Chromebooks, and Chromeboxes,
and all that kind of stuff?
Absolutely.
One of the really important
things to us is making sure
that these apps work across all
devices, no matter whether
you coming in on a Mac, whether
you are coming in on a
PC, whether you're coming
in on a Chromebox.
All of these APIs will work
across all these places.
There may be a few today that
don't work on a Chrome OS
machine, just because there's
a little bit more to
implementing them,
that we haven't
finished that stuff yet.
But we are working
on these things.
I do also want to call out that
you could start writing
these today using Chrome
Stable, Chrome Beta.
It's also in Chrome Dev
and Chrome Canary.
My personal set up, so that
I've always got a stable
browser and a development
browser that's sort of on the
cutting edge of things, is
I keep Beta as my primary
browser and then I keep
Canary installed.
So that way I can always check
to see how things are coming
down the pipe.
Hussain also wanted to know if
Chrome apps are going to be
available on Google TV.
So because we're going
to wrap these as--
will be available as Android
apps as well, I
would suspect so.
I don't see any reason
why not.
I've not actually sat
down and written a
Google TV app before.
So I'm not 100% sure
on that one.
But we'll have a look at that.
I'm really impressed with
all the questions.
There's a ton of really great
questions here, guys.
This is fantastic.
So I'll move on to the
next question.
"Will there be apps available
for Chrome OS devices is to
write Chrome apps?" So you
saw me today using my Mac
I really hope so.
That's the one thing I think
Chrome OS is missing.
And there are a few web
IDEs available.
And really, now that you've
seen that you can build a
Chrome app, there's no reason
why you couldn't build a
Chrome app development
environment to
write Chrome apps.
So it absolutely can be done.
In fact, I think one of the
sample apps that's up and
available on the repository is
an HTML text code editor.
So I'll go for the next
question here.
Again, another one from Mooseman
on the internet.
I love on the internet.
"How do the limitations
of access--
for example, filesystem,
and getusermedia--
differ between packaged apps
and apps from a server?" So
really, there's no difference.
If the app needs any kind of
permission, you still will
either need to ask for
that permission, or--
and that's done through
the manifest file.
So if you want to use
getusermedia, you'd put the
permission request into
the manifest file.
And then you don't get that pop
up that says, hey, this
app wants to do X, because
you've already given it
permission.
So you still have access
to the filesystem.
You still have access
to getusermedia.
to geolocation.
You don't need to go do anything
crazy to do them.
You just need to make sure that
that request is in the
permissions section of
your manifest file.
So next question
from maxw3st--
"What if you want to make
a communication app?
Something that allows two or
more users to connect with
each other?" Great
question, Max.
And there's a lot of really
easy and great ways to go
about this.
One way that you could do it is
using WebSockets, so that
you have a server sitting up on
your side, but you collect
all the messages and send them
out to the different places.
So through a web socket, being
able to do that bidirectional
communication without having
to do HTTP requests or
anything like that.
You could go so far as to
do XML HTTP requests.
But I think one of the coolest
ones that's just landing now
is the WebRTC API.
WebRTC API allows you to get
access to your camera and
microphone, but also provides
all of the APIs you need to do
peer-to-peer connections to
connect two or more users to
each other and send data
back and forth.
Right now, we do this
through Hangouts or
through something else.
But you could do that
exactly through--
write your own Chrome
app to do this.
So really easy to be able to do
that, same way as you'd go
through and do this as
any other web app.
Halyavin wants to know, "How you
project your laptop screen
to us without using the
internet?" So we have a rather
fun set up in our studios.
I actually have to plug my
laptop into a special box that
gets plugged into another
computer.
I think we should do a Hangout
on how we do our Hangouts
sometime in the future.
I think that would be a little
bit of a fun one.
Fabs from Switzerland wants to
know about the performance of
Chrome mobile apps.
And that's something that's
really important to us.
We want to make sure that these
apps run beautifully.
And that's why we are--
we're not ready to start
sharing them
with the world yet.
One of the things that we're
doing to really try and make
sure that these apps run
beautifully, and these apps
are great, is we're investing
a lot of time on Cordova.
I mentioned this earlier.
By having the engineers
work on Cordova--
so they're actually submitting
code to make Cordova better,
as well is implementing some of
the Chrome APIs that aren't
available today.
So hopefully, that answers
your question, Fabs.
AKFLOW from New York wants to
know, "Can I use WebRTC, and
are there any examples
today?" Yes.
You can absolutely use WebRTC.
Go hit up HTML5rocks.com And
I believe there's a couple
working samples up there and a
couple good tutorials that you
can use to go through and figure
out how to do these.
One of the things that I
just want to put up--
we're almost out of time, so I'm
going to just put up the
link to the documentation
again.
So if you want to go find that
documentation, any of the
resources, or anything like
that, definitely go
check that link out.
Again, it's
developer.chrome.com, and
click on the link that
says Chrome Apps.
VAN RIPER: Pete, could I just
make a plug for a hashtag?
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
VAN RIPER: I mean, if you guys
want to have follow on
discussions on Google+ or
elsewhere, please use the
#chromeapps, all one
word, hashtag.
PETE LEPAGE: Perfect.
Yeah.
So if you do hashtag that stuff,
we try to keep an eye
on for those kinds of things
and respond as best we can.
There's also a mailing list
that if you want to get
involved, you can have
a look there.
I'll add that as one of the
comments afterwards in the
Hangout video on our Google+
page, on the Chrome Developers
Google+ page.
So with that, Djazz from Sweden
wants to know, "Can I
access the native menu bar, or
global menu bar, in OS X in my
app, or should I build my own
with HTML and JavaScript?" So,
Djazz, right now the
answer is no.
You can't access it.
It is something we're trying
to figure out how to do and
how to get it to work right,
because it's something that's
really important to us.
But we haven't been able to
figure out how to get that to
work right.
Under certain operating systems
and certain things,
some things are restricted.
And unfortunately, that's
one of them.
So we're trying to see if it's
something that's possible.
I would recommend, for the time
being, writing your own
in HTML and JavaScript, but
doing it in such a way that
you know that if we do get it,
you can quickly and easily
remove it, and you're just
calling a set of APIs.
So I'm going to take one more
question, and then we'll wrap
up for today.
And Dex, your question-- you
get to be the last one.
Congratulations.
"Can Chrome apps run in the
background be launched remotely?
For example, tap a button on
your phone, opens a full
screen app on the desktop."
That's an interesting
question, and in
many ways, yes.
I haven't actually tried it.
But theoretically, there should
be no reason why you
can't do that.
So you remember before, where we
had our listen for launched
listener in our main.js, there's
no reason why you
couldn't put a listener in
there that listens on a
WebSocket, listens on something
else, that says,
when you hear this particular
thing, great.
Open the new window.
And I lied.
I'm going to take two more
questions, because there's two
more really good questions that
I want to hit in here.
The next question, "Why is
localStorage not available in
Chrome apps?
And is there any way to
use a Sync version of
chrome.storage.local in apps?
Async read/write is a
pain to work with."
I agree with you on that
pain to work with.
I was struggling with it
a little bit yesterday.
But there are ways around it,
and there's some good things
that you can do.
It's not available for a couple
of reasons, and the
primary reason being that
local storage, being
synchronous, is terribly slow.
If you actually go and look at
some of the analytics that
people have done to see how fast
it runs, it's actually
one of the slowest things
that you can do.
It slows down your app a lot.
So by using async and forcing
you to go that way, we're
really trying to target on
performance, making sure that
your apps run fast.
So Ronny, I hope that answers
your question.
I know it's a little bit fun.
But there are some really good
ways of being able to make it
less of a pain, to
put it politely.
And then the final question--
Ryan, in Connecticut.
"Can I write Chrome packaged
apps using Dart?" Not yet.
But the team's working on it.
It is something that a bunch
of people have asked for.
And it is something that
we are working on.
Wow.
That was an hour?
There were a ton of fantastic
questions.
And there's a lot more really
great questions in here.
I'll try and take a look through
these questions and
respond to the questions
inline over
the next day or so.
But if you see me on Google+,
add me to your circles and
keep an eye on me there.
You should also add the Chrome
Developers to your circles, if
you don't already have that in
your circles, and follow that.
So with that, I'll say, thank
you guys, very much.
This was wonderful.
And Van, I'll pass it
back over to you.
VAN RIPER: Well, thank
you, Pete.
This was a great inaugural GDG
All Hands, and I'm looking
forward to doing many more of
these in the months ahead.
Thank you, Pete.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
All right.
Thank you.
And thank you to everybody.